(man) the sharks are back.
They're looking for the best
products and Businesses
America has to offer.
The only thing that really
matters--What is it? Money.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
there's two type of people in
this world.
There's either sharks
and the rest of the people
who want to be sharks.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Don't let these guys off-Put you
by their fancy talk.
You know what?
What fancy talk?
Fancy Talk.
Their valuation is nuts.
You know what? You can just
kick him in the head.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
Can you help us take this where
we need to go with this thing?
It's sink...
Nobody would buy this.
Or swim.
I just want to make
a ton of money.
That's it.
Wrong Answer.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-Made,
filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Barbara Corcoran
turned a $1,000 loan
into a real estate Empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-Filled city
of Manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-Shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-Made,
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
My name is Nick Romero.
I'm 30 years old, and I live
in Venice beach, california.
♪♪
Venice is such a creative place,
and my store
is Completely based off
creativity.
♪♪
My store is called the ave,
and there's no place
like it in the world.
What we do is, we allow
for people to come in
and custom create
any article of clothing--
Hats, shirts,
shoes, anything.
And it's made right there
While they wait.
My store is really small,
but that doesn't stop people
from coming in.
There have been times
where there's been
a line out the door
where people have been waiting
just to come in
and get something done.
♪♪
As much as I love Venice,
and Venice
will always be my home,
I really have aspirations
to grow this business
all over the world.
I need the sharks to make
an investment,
and I need their expertise.
I can't wait to present
this product to them.
I think they're
absolutely gonna love it
just as much as I do.
And I really think
that We're gonna make
millions of dollars together.
♪♪
Hey, guys.
My name is Nick Romero,
and I'm the owner of the ave.
I'm here to ask for $125,000
in exchange
for 15% of my business.
We are living
in the digital era.
Current technology has created
so many different ways
for people to create
their own music,
they're own art,
they're own photography.
Now more than ever,
people have a need
to express themselves.
And one way in which
young people in particular
are desperately trying to show
their individuality
is through their clothing.
That's why I created
the ave.
The ave will be
the first retail chain
in the entire world
that will allow you
to custom create
any article of clothing
that can be made
within minutes.
It'll be a place where you
can turn your images,
your ideas, and your slogans
into wearable art,
from head to toe.
Right now,
our most popular Product
is getting your favorite style
of shoe completely customized.
Let me show you
how that's done.
We can take any image--
Like you guys here--
or images.
We can completely redesign it
for you.
All you gotta do--Pick out
your favorite style of shoe.
♪♪
And using
my patented Printing process...
(beeps)
(whirring)
We can have your custom kicks
ready in minutes.
This process is the core
of the ave's popularity.
This is why rock stars,
movie stars,
teenagers, grandmas,
people from all over the world,
are currently ordering gear
from us on a regular basis.
So I'm gonna put an ave
in every city in the world.
But in order to do that,
I'm gonna need a little help.
So why don't you guys
check these out?
(Robert) Yep.
♪♪
Pretty cool.
(daymond) So this is a laser?
This is
a digital garment printer
that I modified
using this piece here,
and I've built
four different pieces
that match with
different styles of shoes.
(daymond)
So you have a store now?
I have a store.
It's in Venice, california.
All of our inventory is Blank.
What that does is creates
a situation
where we don't actually
make the product
until someone orders it.
So we're eliminating
a middle man,
which drives up our margins.
Uh, when we sell shoes online,
all we do is have product shots.
When people place the order,
then we actually make the shoe.
What's your background?
Um... (chuckles)
Never went to college.
Um, when I was 18,
I... made up a phony resume,
got a job at a massive company,
worked there for three years.
Oh, that makes me trust you.
Well... (laughs)
(Robert and Barbara laugh)
He wouldn't be the first
to do it, either.
I know.
I was 18 years old,
and I had nothing to lose.
I still have nothing to lose.
I'm a hard worker,
and I--and I get things done.
So, Nick,
how much does it cost?
For a custom shoe with your
images, we charge 100 Bucks.
Including the cost
of the shoe?
That's right.
And what does that
cost you to do,
including the cost
of printing?
It costs about $27, $28.
(Robert) Including the shoe?
That's correct.
So, Nick, this all comes down
to the machine.
It actually c--
Not the machine,
it actually comes down
to this platen,
because no one in the world
is doing this,
and no one can do this
because--
to the what, Nick? Sorry.
We call it a platen.
It's this metal device--
(mark) bladen?
That holds the shoe up,
and what I've done is,
I've created a template
for each size.
So the printer
will actually know
exactly where to spray
the ink.
So there are
how many different styles?
Right.
Well, there's all these here.
You know, we've got,
you know, these slip-On shoes,
we've got the boots there,
also these shoes up here.
You can see--You know, what--
got it. Okay.
Right.
So then you made
the modifications to this.
Right.
And so anybody can come in
with any picture,
anything at all?
Right.
I mean, we--
We've gone as far--
We've taken pictures
of people's tattoos
right in the store,
cut it out on photoshop,
printed it on their shoes.
How long does it take?
Less than 30 minutes.
Do I really need
a retail store?
Why isn't this
a complete online business?
Well, we've been V--
My store
is only 450 square feet.
It's tiny.
We've generated $570,000
since we opened,
which was
in mid April of last year.
$570,000...
that's right.
In your first year?
That's right.
You didn't mention
anything about profit.
The profit was $150,000.
So how are you gonna
make this a chain?
It's gonna be done
in phases, okay?
Phase One is where
We're at now, small scale.
450 Square feet
is not a lot of space
when this enormous printer
is taking up--
So you want to make
bigger stores?
The--Phase two is to open up
a bigger store,
release the other shoe styles
that we have the technology for,
then at that point, I want
to look into franchising.
How many machines do you have
in the store, one?
We have one.
Right, so you can't make
that many
if it takes
up to 30 minutes, right?
Okay, here's the thing--
Each Retail store
is open regular hours
just like any retail store,
but at night, they turn into
fulfillment centers.
You see
this button right here?
Right. But you see what I'm--
this--hold on. Hang on.
This button is green
for a reason--
Because every time we press it,
we make money.
(mark laughs)
right?
Oh, I like that.
(laughs)
Nick, how much does
the printer cost you?
It cost $55,000.
You altered the Printer.
Can anybody else do that?
No. We've--like I said,
we've got these in--
--In patent pending right now,
so, I mean...
then why aren't we leasing
this printer
to everybody in the country
or the world--
Why would you
ignore the fact--
I started a business--
I'm gonna ignore it
because I've backed
about four or five
REALLY cool brands like yours,
and they're usually cool
and they're broke.
But We're not a brand.
There's two types of people
in this world.
There's either sharks
and the rest of the people
who want to be sharks.
That's it.
(laughs)
and I'm trying to get you
to be a shark.
Okay.
Right? So if this technology
is Good enough
where we can lease people
the printer for $100,000
and get a percentage--
I don't care if they do
just their families,
they do bar mitzvah--
I don't care what they do.
That's one thing,
but the--the other part of it
that I--that we haven't
really talked about yet
that I think is Really important
is licensing images, right?
When you walk into an ave,
you're gonna see
touch screens
all over the wall
with thousands--
Thousands of images
that people can just sit there
and go through.
They can spend hours...
(daymond) Nick, you know what?
Looking at pictures...
Nick.
And looking
at different stuff--
Nick, Nick, hold it
one second.
You're trying to work hard
instead of working smart.
I think you're--
You're incredibly cool,
but I've lost a lot of money
with the cool guys.
They're still cool, but not--
and I was broke, you know,
after--After investing in 'em,
so with that, I'm out.
(mark) He's right,
but that doesn't diminish
the opportunity.
The question is,
what's the special sauce?
And that's, what'd you call it,
your platum or--
Platen.
Yeah, your platen, right?
And that's what's unique.
And if you can take that
and market it to other people
and let them do all the work,
you can have fun with the ave
and make money off the ave,
and that's all good--
That's the problem
with this deal.
Everybody has a different
version of the business model,
including you.
Well, no,
it's the same version.
It's the same version,
it's just, where's the leverage?
I think Nick Sees the leverage
as being open up a lot of stores
'cause it's cool and hip
and we'll grow it, right?
What's proprietary
is that single plate
that holds those shoes in place.
(Robert) Mark's got
the big picture down here.
I think the problem is, Nick is
seeing the little picture today.
That concerns me a lot.
I don't want to change
the guy's business model,
and at this point,
for me,
I'm out.
Now look,
here's the thing you guys--
I just want to make
a ton of money. That's it.
I'm already to the point where I
have employees doing the work.
I'm never
in the store anymore.
I'm trying to grow it.
That's why I'm here.
That's why I'm in front of you,
and that's why I'm here,
to say I want to have
a partner that has done it.
You guys have done it.
And at the end of the day,
it's all about money.
Right, Mr. Wonderful?
That's so True,
my friend.
I'm listening to you,
and you're saying,
"look, I want to do retail,
I want to license images."
I-I appreciate the fact
you have $500,000 in Sales.
That's interesting.
But the rest of it's moving
parts to me, and I hate retail,
so I'm out.
Okay.
(Barbara) I love
your enthusiasm, okay?
But you know what I think?
I think you're in love
with the retail business.
I think you heard
a couple of great ideas
to really make money
on this business,
and you're "Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah,"
but I don't think
you're really listening,
so I'm out.
So it's me and you, baby.
(laughs)
What are we doing?
Let's do something, mark.
♪♪
Four sharks are out,
and mark cuban
is Nick's last chance
to get a deal.
(Kevin)
What are you doing, mark?
I had never sold a t-Shirt
in my life
before April, 7, 2010.
And--and now I'm--I'm living
the L.A. Life,
like, off the store.
♪♪
How much are you
paying yourself?
Basically,
the profits were $150,000,
and the way
that I've been running it,
since it's just me and,
you know, all my employees,
you know,
after everything's paid,
after all the store's paid,
it, you know,
that money's been going--
Just goes in my account,
but I've been using it to--
I've been using it to get
other equipment and to--
So--'cause that--That--
that leads to a big question.
So if were partners...
right.
I give you 125 grand, right?
You can't just put some in
your pocket, put some to work,
put some in your pocket--
No, it would all go to work.
It would all go--
So you're not gonna
pay yourself anything?
Well, I mean,
after we opened the--
After We would open
the next store
and get the website
and stuff going, I mean,
you know, there's--there--
the money's gonna come in.
I mean,
as soon as we open up.
What if it doesn't?
Well, I'm--I'm willing
to take the risk,
because I've taken
the risk thus far.
So what will you pay yourself?
'cause you're not just gonna
live off of nothing, right?
Right.
Well, I mean,
if you gave me the investment,
um, there's still
enough money--
There's still gonna be
enough money for me to live,
and phase two--
but that's the whole thing.
It's not like, hey, there's
money in the cash register,
and you just take money out.
I don't expect to make
a million dollars tomorrow.
I mean, it's gonna obviously
be years of--
how much do you need
to get paid?
You know, I mean,
I'm comfortable
for the next few years
if I'm making six Figures.
That's what
I'm comfortable with,
like for the next year
or two, until--
but yeah, in the end,
I want millions, you know?
I ain't gonna pay you
six figures.
I want you to sweat.
I want you to--
To be scared...
scared out of your mind
because you're not
getting paid anything,
and 100% of that money
is going into the business.
That's how it's been
since I was 21 years old.
I've--I've always made
my own money.
I'm not afraid to work, mark.
But there's nobody who's--
There's nobody who's hungry
That's paying Themselves
6-Plus figures.
Well, I'm--I'm saying,
I'm willing to put in the work.
I know that it's a Winner,
and do you--
Are you gonna have
an offer for me?
♪♪
If you woulda told me
you're still in the store
12 to 15 hours a day,
if you woulda told me,
you live to sell shoes
and live to sell this,
as opposed to working
on the software,
if you hadn't told me you were
living the L.A. Lifestyle,
which led me to ask
the question
of how much are you
paying yourself...
right.
And then
you come back and say,
"you know, I can live off
of six figures"...
the right answer was,
"I can live off
of macaroni and cheese."
I've done it before.
Yeah.
I'm not saying you haven't.
But once you've left that,
it's hard to go back to it.
Like I said, I'm willing
to put in whatever it takes.
I don't sp--I don't
do anything else but work.
But you missed what he said.
He basically said,
he can give you everything,
but he can't give you adversity.
And adversity
makes all the difference.
If I get the investment,
I'm gonna open up
another store,
and it's gonna be more work than
opening up the one that I did,
and I'm ready for that.
I'm out.
All right.
Thanks, you guys.
♪♪
All he had to say was, "Hey,
I'm willing to give up the steak
and go back
to the Mac and cheese."
When he said--
look, when he said,
"you know, I could live okay
on six figures"...
Yeah, come on.
Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing,
Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing.
I'm out.
How many people in America
make six figures?
Not these days.
That's right.
Okay, I-I don't need
to go back to eating
macaroni and cheese
to--to know what adversity is.
I know what it is. I've dealt
with it my whole life.
And I've worked--I've worked
hard to get where I'm at,
and there's no reason to take
any steps--steps back.
Last season, we watched
Darryl and Randy Lenz
strike a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their child Carrier
ride-On carry-On.
Great. Thank you. Whoo-Hoo!
Great Decision.
Let's see where they are now.
♪♪
(Darryl)
Since our episode aired,
sales have gone through
the roof.
Before "Shark tank,"
our Sales were $40,000.
And in the six months
since "Shark tank" Aired,
our sales have gone
to half a million dollars.
(man) What's going on?
(Darryl)
it has been a whirlwind.
We could not have done it
without Barbara.
Ooh, my gosh. I can't believe
it's finally here.
Think it's a full truck?
(Darryl) We just received
our new shipment of chairs.
Mwah.
Barbara Really wanted
to help us redesign our chair
that looks Good.
(Randy) Everything's
more upscale and up to date.
Oh, wow.
The New Colors look great.
The box looks great.
We're really happy with
the ride-On carry-On now.
(singsongy) Here we go.
Ever since "Shark tank,"
people say,
"Oh, you're still a pool man?"
and I say,
"Yeah, I'm still a pool man
"and--and Darryl's still
a flight attendant,
"But the way sales are going,
we might not be doing that
much longer."
Mwah.
♪♪
Next into the shark tank
is Blake St. Clair,
with a product designed
for man's best friend.
♪♪
Hello.
I am Blake St. Clair,
entrepreneur, designer,
and creator of the first-Ever
full-Serving meal
for your favorite pet.
I am asking $100,000
for a 51% stake in my company.
People love their animals,
travel with them everywhere,
and yet, there's still not
an easy way to feed on the go.
♪♪
Why travel
with bowls, bags, water,
and towels to clean up with?
I introduce to you
the perfect solution--
Barkem's to go!
The first-Ever prepackaged meal
especially for your pet.
In separate compartments
are one full serving
of premium food--
Portioned for different sizes
and species of pets,
vitamin-Enhanced water,
and a treat
separately packaged for later.
This is where food, water,
and treat Unite.
Barkem's to go!
Is Ideally marketed
towards the traveling pet owner
that would just like
an easy alternative
to feed on the go.
Simply open the container,
and feed it to your dog.
Barkem's to go!
Is a great product
that has a demand, a market,
and is just waiting
to be on every shelf.
Grab your dog a barkem's
and Let's go.
It looks pretty messy
down there.
It looks messy?
Mm-Hmm.
(Robert) I think Barbara's point
is, a large dog like that
is gonna make a mess out--
That is correct, and that's
where, uh, different sizes for--
for specific sizes
and different animals--
Uh, There'd be a small
for your--your small dogs,
There'd be a medium
and a large.
So is that a small,
medium, or a large dog
that we're watching here?
This is the large Dog.
Uh-huh.
You seem to not--
(laughing)
(mark) Shut the front door!
He's a large dog?
Are you kidding me?
(laughs)
Oh, my gosh.
Can I see the pa--
the packaging, please?
Yes.
Can I see the dog?
(laughs)
(Barbara laughs)
What's the dog's name?
The Dog's name is Rummy.
Rummy?
Here, Rummy. Hey, rummy.
(Robert) Hey, rummy.
(clicks tongue)
Rummy. Come here, baby.
Come here.
Is that the meal size
for the large dog?
This is actually
for the medium dog.
I see.
The larger one would be
a larger package.
Handsome dog.
Okay.
Handsome guy.
Barbara, big dog.
A large dog.
(daymond laughs)
(mark) Blake, let me ask you
a couple of questions.
Yes.
This is basically
lunchables for a pet, right?
Exactly.
And it could be applied
to other pets as well, right?
That is correct.
So, Blake, why wouldn't I,
as a dog owner,
simply take a baggie,
throw some dried pet food in it,
and take it with me?
What's the difference?
What value are you adding
with that packaging?
You could easily do that,
and that's what most people do
right now all the time.
So then why are you
solving a problem at all?
This product probably has
no market whatsoever.
Because you wouldn't have to
travel with the entire--
All the extra stuff.
No, but wouldn't I just--
if they have
two different flavors
of dried whatever it is
that they like,
I'll throw both of those
into the bag,
and when the dog's hungry,
I'll just
open the bag,
let 'em eat it.
It's not necessarily
for everyday use.
It could be as a novelty,
it could be for weekend use,
or just as a convenience,
like if you're
gonna go Camping.
Uh, you're going camping
for three days.
Yeah, but I mean,
I'm questioning
the viability
of your whole idea.
I think there May be
zero value here.
Absolutely Nobody
would buy this.
I don't know why
anybody would need this.
(Robert) But, uh, you know what?
I-I got--I gotta tell you,
I have a dog.
Uh, it's--It's not a bad idea.
It's a great way to package it.
Is there a--some form
of patent on this?
There is.
I have a patent pending
and I've also trademarked
the name.
You--you have
a patent on it?
Pending.
I do, Indeed.
See, Blake, I think
it's a good idea,
because when I travel
with the dog, right now
you gotta grab this food, you
gotta throw it in a plastic bag.
It's--It's just
a lot of work.
The other thing
I really like is,
for a large food company,
it's just another way
for them to sell product.
Have you made
any of those calls?
I have tried personally
to contact
a few different
pet food vendors,
and I have not gotten anywhere
with my research.
You know why?
'cause it's a worthless idea.
(laughs)
You know what? You can just
kick him in the head.
No, you don't.
And like I say,
I've presented this
to hundreds of people...
Hey, rummy...
and not anybody has said
that it was a worthless idea.
Kill.
Well, now you found the truth.
I-I would like to say
that many people say that
they would buy it themselves.
Um, old and young,
uh, all--
but have--
Has anybody bought it?
No, this is
a prototype only.
It's a prototype?
It has not been marketed.
It has never been for sale.
(Barbara) What do you
sell that for?
What would the stores
It would sell for between
$2.50 and $3.00 a package.
And how much would
it cost you to make it?
It costs 64 cents
to make the package.
(daymond) the food as well?
That's the food
not included.
The food
would have to be licensed
to a pet food company
with the package
as
the--the--the ultimate design.
Blake, I'm gonna say--
I'm gonna say--
Blake, the only play here
is the packaging, right?
That's what you're suggesting?
(Blake) That is correct.
Right.
Oh.
(Kevin) I'll make it
real easy.
This idea
has absolutely no merit,
and it's completely worthless.
Do not quit your day job.
I'm out.
Thank you.
What are you
thanking me for?
(chuckles) I just
told you the truth.
Because he's--
because he's well-Mannered.
♪♪
You know, Blake, obviously,
you're early in the process.
You're offering 51%
of the company.
There's a lot of work
to be done,
and I really don't think
I can help you.
I'm out.
♪♪
Here's a quick question--
Y-Your Pat pending--
What--What is
the patent gonna be on?
The patent is fully on
the design of the product.
The utility Patent
would follow shortly after,
um, once the financing
was there.
You would fully protect it,
put it into cats,
put it into many other areas
and other animals.
You think you're gonna be
able to get a patent
on just putting dog st--
Uh, food
in a container like this?
The packaging? Yes. The utility
patent can be obtained, um--
and then nobody else
will be able to do this?
Do you think that is reality?
That is correct.
No, I don't think
that's possible.
Yeah.
I don't think that's reality,
and I think
you're a little too soon.
I like the idea,
and actually, uh,
my dog's name is Blake.
(laughs)
really?
Yes, really.
But I'm out.
I don't think
you have a problem
with Putting dry food
in a baggie.
I do it with my dog
for a day--
slam it in the baggie.
Then I use the same bag
to clean up after him.
I don't think people
are gonna spend the money
to solve a problem that
doesn't exist, so I'm out.
All right.
Thank you much.
Don't miss this opportunity,
Robert.
Uh, well--
at $2.50, I can't see
how it wouldn't
simply be just
a-a convenience.
Blake, un-Unlike my...
evil twin here,
I do have animals,
and I love my animals,
and I do think
it's a great idea.
But...
(bell dings)
You're way too early.
You're way too early.
You gotta get some interest
from a licensing perspective.
You can do that.
Pick up the phone. You created
this product. Keep going.
Right.
Love the dog.
I'm out for the business.
Thank you.
(mark)
We're all about, Blake.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Best of Luck.
Good luck with everything.
Could I have my dog back?
No, you can't. We love him.
(daymond) No, he's hanging.
All right.
He was out, too.
So can I have $100,000
for 51% of the dog?
You're selling the dog now?
(mark) Oh, man!
(Robert) He's joking.
Oh, man.
Thank you so much.
(Barbara) Thank you, Blake.
(daymond) All right. Thank you.
(mark) All right.
Good luck with Everything.
Love the Dog.
(mark) Thanks, Blake.
Thank you.
(Barbara) Thank you.
(daymond) Thank you.
♪♪
I feel like I put
a lot of time into this,
and then they said it was
an ABSOLUTELY pointless product,
and I don't feel that way.
I think barkem's is gonna be
the next great pet innovation,
and I think that it'll--It'll be
on every shelf Soon.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Steve Albert,
and these are my partners.
I'm Larry Blackwell.
And I'm Jason Conroy.
We are seeking $125,000
for a 15% equity share
in our company--
the Brewer's cow
beer infused ice cream.
(chuckles)
(Steve) I have been making
super-Premium ice cream
for over ten years now.
I started an experiment
in the pairing
of two of Life's
greatest pleasures--
Beer and ice cream.
Today the Brewer's cow
reverse engineers the beer,
rendering it alcohol-Free.
We then add
other ingredients to it,
typical of what
a craft Brewer would use,
and we blend it
with our premium cream.
Our ideas for flavors
are only limited
by the amount of good beer
out there.
And we all know, there's
a lot of good beer out there.
(Jason) Sharks, partnering
with you will allow us
to take this company
to the next level.
We hope to have
our beer-Infused ice cream
in supermarkets nationwide.
Our unique niche will allow us
to break into
this highly competitive market
of ice cream.
Even a 1% share of that market
would make this company
a multi-Multi-Million-Dollar
company.
(Steve) sharks,
our barmaid Claire
is gonna serve you
some samples
of our bavarian brittle.
Yes, for you.
Guten tag, Claire.
(mark) Oh.
Cheers.
Okay, guys. Cheers.
Oh, wow.
You guys did it--
ice cream and beer,
and it tastes Good.
Put a lot of hard work
into that recipe.
(daymond) So, guys,
I'm lactose intolerant, so...
if I taste that, then
the whole room will clear out,
and instead of doing that,
I'm out.
♪♪
Actually,
I'm lactose intolerant.
I just don't care,
'cause this is good.
I'm lack of sales intolerant.
I want to know
if you have any sales.
We've really only been
in business for one year.
We spent the first
three or four months
selling to restaurants
and ice cream shops,
we sold $5,000 worth
of ice cream.
Last fall,
we shifted our gears
to the retail market.
We're doing
our first production run
and putting ice cream
on the shelves
of whole foods Market.
Is that a long answer--
"No, I don't have any sales"?
Well, it's we have $5,000
worth of sales.
(mark) So you said
you have an order
that you need the cash
to fulfill.
How big an order is it?
The order is starting off
at 50 pints a store,
but we make--we--
give me a dollar amount.
A dollar amount would be
$100 per order.
You need money in order
to fulfill a $200 order?
No, no, no, no. We--we--
the money you're gonna
make $200 off of?
No, we can handle that.
We can handle that.
We can handle
this production run.
(Robert) So what's
the total dollar--
We want to do
multiple production runs.
What's the total dollar value
of the order?
The value of the order
is probably, uh,
what are we, $2 times 50...
(mutters)
$200.
(Kevin) $200?
No, no, it can't be.
What do you sell
each pint of ice cream for?
$2, to whole foods.
Okay.
We sell it for $4.
We--it costs us $2.
$4 to whole foods.
We--we sell it for $4.
(laughs) This is like
who's on first?
(laughs)
Wait. Wait. Wait.
What is this, lowest--
lowest in the room--
100 times 4
is $400, Robert.
Mark, they need cash
for a $400 order?
No, that's not what he's Saying.
That's not what he's Saying.
That's what I'm asking.
The total order, everything,
all stores,
that whole foods
is giving you today.
$400.
What's the--
$400
400 Bucks.
(laughing)
(Barbara) gentlemen,
I don't want to be in business
with you guys
with those kind of answers.
I'm out.
(Kevin) Okay, you got ten guys
that like ice cream.
How many want to buy
a beer-Flavored ice cream?
And you're talking guys, men?
I don't care. Women, men,
dogs, cows, Goats.
Um, 9 out of 10
want to try it,
and, uh, 8--8 out of 10
want to try it again.
I think you're wrong.
Uh, n--I-I beg to differ.
So what does it take
in terms of volume
for you guys to be profitable?
If we were to get, I would say,
probably 20 whole Foods.
Dollars.
Um...
uh-Oh.
Uh-Oh.
Between what we've invested
in it, w--I mean, $50,000.
(Robert) Here's my--
My real issue.
I think you gotta know
your numbers.
I mean, you guys had
a VERY hard time
answering my question,
O'Leary's question,
cuban's question.
And it made me think you guys
just met each other outside
as you came down the hallway.
(laughs)
(Jason)
We're ice cream makers.
(Robert) I hear you,
but there are certain things
in every business,
you gotta know
every morning when you wake up,
and one of them is,
what do I need to do
in order to break even.
For that reason, I'm out.
(mark)
You guys have challenges.
You gotta sell thousands
and thousands of pints
in order for us to even
think about getting a return.
You might be better off going to
the big ice cream companies
and licensing your product.
That's your opportunity,
but I can't be an investor,
because you'd have to sell
so many pints of ice cream,
it would take too much capital,
so for that reason, I'm out.
I'm out 'cause I think you guys
are ice cream bozos.
No national Chain's
ever gonna pick this up.
We respect your decision,
but I think we're gonna
go forward.
(Robert) So are we all out?
Yeah, I think we're all out.
Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
Let's go get a beer.
Who's in?
Did you like the ice cream?
Yes.
I didn't.
(Jason) We're ice cream makers.
We're not accountants.
We were looking for somebody
to kind of help us out
with that end of it,
uh, so we could take care
of the ice cream end of it,
which we know is awesome.
And, uh, we're gonna
prove 'em wrong Anyway.
♪♪
Next into the shark tank
is gogo gear,
a business geared towards
motorcycle Enthusiasts.
♪♪
Very cool.
(Barbara) Oh, you're a girl.
So are you.
My name is Desiree Estrada,
and this is my partner,
Arlene battishill.
And we are gogo gear.
We are here today to ask you
for a $300,000 investment
in return for 15% equity.
Gogo gear is
a line of fully protective
safety wear
for people who ride
scooters and motorcycles.
(Arlene)
But very fashionable.
Desiree and I used to ride
to work,
and we were in business suits,
and there is no way
either one of us
or anybody else in the world
that wears business SUITS
or has to be dressed up
to go somewhere
is gonna wear
something like this.
So we're out there riding
with nothing protective.
In, uh, 2008, We both lost
our corporate jobs,
and I said to Desiree,
"I have a great idea.
"Let's take all of our money
and invest it in something
we know nothing about."
(laughs)
Yeah!
(all laugh)
It's the Kevin O'Leary
school of business.
(desirée) yes!
I'm gonna give you $300,000
of Daymond's money right now.
(all laugh)
This is gogo Gear.
Is gogo gear.
(mark) There you go.
Ooh.
(Barbara) Wow.
Now we're talking, baby.
(daymond) Ohh.
We will wear this to work.
(mark) Yowza, yowza.
I am telling you.
This is fully protective,
fully armored,
abrasion-Resistant
safety wear for motorcycle
and scooter Riders.
(Robert) really?
That jacket is...
you bet.
Every jacket
that you see here
contains protective armor
in the back, shoulders,
and in the elbows.
(Kevin) What are your sales?
We have $172,000 in sales
for last year.
So you design it,
and you send it,
and you outsource it?
Mm-hmm. Yes.
We are operating out of
our home. Very low Overhead.
Who's carrying it?
Right now, they're exclusively
held in motorcycle
and scooter Stores.
Total retail stores
are 25.
And do either of you have any
kind of a fashion background?
No, we don't.
We both have extensive
management background.
We have been businesswomen
for over 25 years.
Let me tell you,
that looks Good.
Okay, so this is a 1-Year event
so far. You're newbies.
Show me I can trust you
with my money.
What are you gonna do
with my money?
Well, we're going
to Europe.
That's not the right answer.
On a vacation?
Wrong Answer.
Big-Time wrong.
(laughter)
No, no, no, no, no.
Here's the thing--
in the United States,
There are 7 million
registered bikes.
But the big market
for our product is in Europe,
because you've got 35 million
registered riders there--
That is a horrible,
horrible,
horrible, horrible--
did I say that was
a horrible answer?
And I'll tell you why.
How many people
are in your company?
Two.
You're working out of
your house.
Yep.
What happens to your business
in your 25 stores
when you guys are both in Europe
trying to figure everything out?
When you grow a business,
it's a babysitting process.
It's like having a child,
right?
Mm-Hmm.
You haven't even hired
your first employee,
and you're already
leaving the country and--
(Arlene) No, that's not
the case. That's not True.
We have made a significant
number of contacts
in the industry overseas.
Again, the same problem--
they do the work for us.
Are you profitable yet?
Well, we would've been
profitable,
except we went to Europe.
Yeah, we've made a lot
of mistakes with our money.
So, Arlene, now you want to make
a mistake on our dime?
No, no, no, no.
See, that's the benefit.
A lot of the mistakes
that we made,
we will not make again.
Okay, Desiree, you said
you put all your money in.
How much was all of that
when you started?
We invested, of our own money,
close to $400,000.
How much do you have left?
Less--a little less
than $100,000.
Let me
ask you ladies something.
Everybody agrees
the Product's good.
Would you agree
to allow me to put
an ankle bracelet
on each of you,
and every time
you said "Europe,"
you got a 50-Volt shock?
(laughs)
(Robert) So, Desiree,
I love motorcycles,
but in one of the rare moments
that I actually
want to listen to daymond,
he's the clothing guy.
(Arlene) Yeah.
He has the expertise.
Daymond, what do you think
of this business?
I think that We're ignoring
the bigger Issue.
Which is
the insane valuation?
Yeah, so, you guys,
did you eat or drink Anything
before midnight last night?
'cause we're about to do
some Surgery.
♪♪
None of the sharks are out,
but the sharks feel
that Arlene and Desiree
have valued their COMPANY
too high.
Why is the value of your
company, nothing proprietary,
worth $2 million?
We believe that our value
should be more than just
uh, a conventional...
(Kevin) Well...
valuation Model.
Let Mr. Wonderful help you,
because you said earlier--
Well, Desiree--
You said earlier that you were
both businesswomen.
In your industry,
companies are valued at
five times free cash flow, okay?
That's a great value
for a big company.
One that's successful,
has market share,
people know the brand,
none of which you have.
I'm not stupid.
♪♪
You made a huge tactical error
by trying to tell me
you're worth 2 million bucks,
which is insane.
You forced me to do something
that I didn't want to do
when I first saw this stuff,
but I'm out.
Oh, no.
We never thought
$2 million--
So why'd you tell me
it's worth 2?
We didn't.
We didn't. He did.
But it--That's what you said.
No, that's what
the numbers equal.
I see
how you're calculating it,
based on the equity--
(sharks laugh)
I'm not calculating that.
Based on the equity...
I'm not calculating.
That we're asking for.
That's just math.
Okay.
Where were you
a manager at?
You are both being dragged
down the street...
(Robert) Sorry.
Sorry, guys. I--
by those motorcycles right now
with these numbers.
Whew.
(Barbara)
You simply thought to yourself,
how far
are we gonna take our dream
and what will it be worth?
It's a mistake everybody Makes.
Don't let these guys...
thank you.
Off-Put you
by their fancy talk.
You know what?
What fancy talk?
Fancy Talk.
Their valuation is Nuts.
Their--your valuation,
I agree, is nuts.
Okay.
How would you value it?
Desiree, look,
that's bad.
Don't come in here,
agree with us that the value
of your business is too high,
and then ask us
what we think.
Well, I haven't agreed--
This is your chance.
You're standing there
asking for money.
Think about it and tell me
what you really think
the business is worth.
(mark) They're telling you
it's worth nothing
because they don't know
what to do,
and they want us to do it
for 'em.
(Arlene)
No, we do know what to do.
(sharks all talking at once)
mark, I'm giving 'em
one more chance.
We just don't have
the money to do it.
(daymond) He's giving you
a chance.
All right, look,
we need some help here.
You think?
(daymond) Go ahead.
Wait. We're dropping out quick.
You better hurry up. Say it.
We have started something
brand-New...
get to the number.
That has never
been thought of before.
Hurry up.
Get to the number.
25% equity.
No, that's not high enough.
Get to the number.
I'd say the number would be--
the final Number would be
about 38%.
(mark laughs) 38%.
(Barbara) 38.
You know what?
You make that decision
the same way you make
every other decision.
Whoomp.
No, we talked about it
before we left.
You took $400,000,
and over the last 2 years,
you haven't been able
to sit down
and define a direct strategy
That's gonna
get you to a point
of profitability and growth.
And I hate to paraphrase
the undertaker over here,
but you know what?
Any brand that has any interest
in this business,
since you have
nothing proprietary,
could just come in and crush you
like the cockroaches you are.
(daymond and Kevin) Yeah!
Well, all right then.
(desirée) Oh, well.
I am out.
Aww.
I am so out,
I am, like, in europe
looking back at you guys.
♪♪
Because of your extreme optimism
and how you
pissed away that money
so quick,
and how you're still dreaming
about Europe
and who knows what next,
I'm out.
Ohh.
(Arlene) Wow. People.
We have got something
that is so innovative.
We don't want to leave
"Shark tank" Without a deal.
Arlene, when you have a product
that's extremely innovative,
but unfortunately,
can be ripped off very easily,
what is the one quality that
you absolutely have to have
in order to be successful?
Absolute laser-Like focus.
Bang.
Here's my market.
I've got motorcycle dealers.
I need 25, I need 35,
I need 45.
Go, go, go.
My biggest fear
with you guys
is that you're not focused.
For that reason,
I'm out.
Wow.
Four sharks are out.
Daymond is Arlene
and Desiree's last chance
to make a deal.
All right, daymond.
You know this business.
We also...
are willing to bring
our equity offer up.
♪♪
What's the equity?
From 38%?
Yes.
What is it now?
Can we step out for a moment?
Do you mind?
Of Course.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah.
Daymond, I'm telling you,
they are scatterbrained.
Some Big guy is gonna knock it
off. Is that your concern?
No, no, no.
Going out and dealing
with Motorcycle accounts--
I have no idea who they are...
(Barbara) Yeah.
How many of them, how to
get ahold of all of them.
I'm gonna leave it up to them
at that point,
and that is challenging.
Daymond,
I know that market.
I can get this into
all the motorcycle shops
across North America
very easily,
but I don't know
the fashion side.
I can do the manufacturing.
But I'm not doing
this deal without you.
All right.
You guys would be crazy
to deal with 'em.
♪♪
All right, ladies, ladies,
before you start,
catastrophic move
in trying
to convince the sharks
that you are worth $2 million.
And you admit it.
However, we have let you
go back and reconsider.
What have you brought back
into the tank?
We are looking for a partner,
and a partner to us would be
50% equity.
While you were out there,
Robert and I
had a conversation.
And Robert brings
something to the table
because he has
a very good relationship
with a lot
of motorcycle shops.
So we want
to counteroffer you.
(Robert)
Here's what I want to know--
you burned through $400,000
of your own money
in a few years.
For you not to burn through
$300,000
of my and Daymond's money,
I gotta have more control.
So how much more than 50%
are you willing to give me?
Um...
we would be willing
to give you
um...
take a breath.
Um... (laughs)
Take a breath.
Thank you.
Slow down.
(both whisper indistinctly)
So we would give you
a greater...
number.
Percentage of equity...
55%.
Than we have.
Not enough for me.
I'm out again.
Not enough?
All right. Hold on, Robert.
Robert...
they came in.
They went from 15% to 38%
to 50% to 55%.
I-I have to respect that
in some sense.
Would you just still come in
if I do 55%?
'Cause I can't do it
without you.
♪♪
Can't do it.
They're--They're...
they're just--
There are so many issues--
the EUROPE--
No, it--
No, it's a challenge.
I know. I know.
I hear what you're saying.
Robert, Robert,
are you in at 65%?
Are you in at 65%?
Can you help us take this
where we need to go
with this thing?
You and daymond together,
take this thing at 65%?
(Arlene) You love the product.
I mean--
I love the PRODUCT,
Arlene,
and that is the only reason
I'm still talking to you.
But my challenge is...
(desirée)
and we're listening to you.
Every time you get asked
a business question,
I hear dreams, I hear hopes,
I hear future.
It's great.
(Arlene)
Like every entrepreneur.
But I gotta hear Business.
That's my Concern.
That's why they need us,
Rob.
That's why
we need you.
We burned through
that $400,00,
and I take responsibility
to that,
because I had a big dream
that we could do this
where we have
distributors interested
in us in Italy...
All right.
In Europe.
Okay, but--
(Robert) Arlene.
Yeah?
The--the--
my bad. My bad, Robert.
(daymond)
Arlene, just--
Come on. Come back
to the table, baby!
But there you are again!
There you are again!
(laughs)
(daymond) rob, this--
400 grand. "My bad."
I just pissed it away, right?
Yeah. No. I didn't do that.
Hey, you know what, Arlene?
$400,000 was a lot of money
to me when I didn't have any.
It's still a lot of money!
It's still
a lot of money to me.
It's still a lot
of money.
I can't do it 'cause you're
throwing that money away.
If daymond wants to throw
his money away,
I'm gonna let him do it.
I'm out.
Ugh.
Ohh.
We--
We were willing to,
you know,
refocus our business.
We are willing to--
to grow our business.
We actually have
a marketing plan for the U.S.
(daymond) guys, listen.
Robert's out.
But I got good news
for you. I'm in.
Whoo!
Aah!
I can't believe it.
Damn.
Thank you!
Oh, my goodness!
All right, so now
I'm betting on you guys.
Don't make me look bad.
We won't.
Not a chance.
All right.
We won't.
Thank you.
Thank you, sharks!
(mark)
Congratulations, ladies.
(laughing)
(Arlene) God!
(Barbara) You're my hero.
Whoo-Hoo!
Oh, god.
(laughing) We got it.
I'm glad we had
our protective armor on,
because we sure took
a beating out there,
but at the end of the day,
we got what we wanted.
And we wanted a deal
with daymond,
and we're ready to go.